okay five four three we're back on
Startalk cosmic queries edition grab bag
questions that came to us from all over
the internet all over the internet oh
and this is the final segment yes so of
course it being this final segment this
has to be our lightning range the
lightning round we're packing as many
answers as I can that's right go for
here we go let's start off with Steve
Kramer this one from Facebook in space
no one can hear you scream but you can
hear yourself a friend and I have
actually conflicting views on this we
know that there is no air to allow your
voice to read your ears but he brought
up bone conduction that might be able to
get a hum up scream okay I don't know
change the pressure with force of the
air out so you wouldn't have it what do
you think no it's not what I think it's
just what the laws of physics are okay
what right oh so you need air to move
sound from you to the other person
correct but there is just a thing that
vibrates your body is a vibratory medium
especially the rigid objects such as
your teeth and your bones so yeah if you
like you can so hear that in fact you
might even be able to hear your
heartbeat so definitely you can hear
your own body a digestive and
malfunctions in space sweet sweet all
right let's move on this is from Michael
Shambo Michael says I just finished
reading space Chronicles and it wasn't
absolute delight Thank You Neil you can
say you're welcome my question is it
burns or any other animal capable of
flight never existed on planet earth but
the rest of the world didn't change as
we know it what humans have ever
developed a need or a want to fly or
would it have just taken us more time to
have that need if as it was it took us a
long time as if why we didn't fly until
one hundred and ten years ago so and
we've been around for thousands of years
so the existence of birds
apparently didn't speed up that process
right all right so I think we still
would have flown we have
clever folks out there we would have
seen paper flutter to the ground we have
invented a glider might taking a little
longer but I so think we would have been
up there flying and been on the moon
nice guy all right
mm-hmm okay here we go this is from
Anthony combs what implications does the
recent discovery of recording
temperatures lower than absolute zero
have on science most particular the
implication that I'm seeing on the
interwebs about how it exhibits
properties of dark matter this is a
fascinating question right I'm read the
research paper that talked about
temperatures below absolute zero and I
didn't understand the word so I cannot
answer that but if you but at generally
speaking when you go to when you take
matter to a state has never been in when
you explore the universe on energies
never reached new things rise up and new
explanation for previously held
long-standing points of ignorance or
sometimes solved so yeah we can all be
hopeful that people are finding new ways
to take matter so let go sweet
I like the answer uh Caroline hello this
is what she says on an episode of Doctor
Who parts of the universe exploded due
to very complicated string of events and
the stars exploded that got me thinking
how would this affect us if there were
suddenly no more stars excluding the Sun
there still was a Sun in the episode
what would the consequences be okay so
in other words what she's asking is
nothing but our solar system right what
were the consequences consequences of
nothing but our sources okay there be no
consequences whatsoever you wouldn't
have Neil Young song there's southern
across what's that song is it either
what sings it to be will we be missing
songs right in the repertoire all right
do we the Stardust Memories hey do we
did right hey maybe they don't all right
pretty much a lot of art we go a lot of
art without our a it would be I think a
little bit culturally impoverished but
we still
nice okay this is from Derek Derek wants
to be in other words the distance stars
have no meaningful effect on anything we
do in our everyday life oh no Derek I've
recently started watching Doctor Who
another doctor who questioned and
everything Ellen did order to be to be
more accurate every episode they have
some freaky science phenomenon which
makes me scoff at the television without
spoiling anything in one episode Doctor
Who's spaceship which is a police box
tugs the planet earth back into its
regular place in the solar system after
it was stolen and dumped in a void in
the universe this leads me to my
question thank God what would happen to
a planet that somehow was being tugged
throughout the universe and is it
possible to calculate how much force
will be necessary to pull that planet
yes and by the way a police box could
tow a planet
the doctors police box can tow a planet
because of course the police box is
bigger on the inside that's right when
you're that then you can have any
massive launch and any power just let
the man have his day as it's cantered
dimension it and let the man have his
day it's right but otherwise we will
surely have to learn how to start towing
planet when the Sun becomes a red giant
because it will expand and if we don't
move out behind farther away from the
Sun we will incinerate as the oceans
come to a rolling boil and evaporates
into the atmosphere the appareil
atmosphere evaporates into space and we
are a charred
ember burning deep within the gaseous
envelope of the Sun we will want to live
farther away from the Sun when that
happens we better figure out how to tow
happy thoughts
okay I thought brilliant gunnery Taylor
go ahead I know nothing about astronomy
but but it doesn't make sense the most
distant galaxies that we say we're
looking back 13 million years at the
beginning of the Big Bang
basically how can we say that how can we
say that first it's 13 billion like 13
billion years ago because it's taken
like that long to reach us that's how
far away the damn thing is Chuck I don't
see you as you are but as you once were
free bill 3 billions of a second ago
I've changed in the past so the farther
away you are the more you see into its
past it's that simple
Oh actually I missed a double for the
previous one
there you go we have ended start on the
lightning round across Macquarie's
edition I'm Neil deGrasse Tyson Chuck
nice thanks for being here it's a
pleasure we work to impart by a grant
from the National Science Foundation as
always keep looking up man that was a
lot of stuff a lot of stuff has a lot
that's interesting because most radio is
a little more stately than that now that
I think about it just let's talk how do
you feel about Obama writing I say oh
well I did some research and I think
he's this and we're just blown through
the universe that's quite unique radio I
think they did it this because it's
literally like I said any time you can
go from meteor showers to Abraham
Lincoln you're doing something right you
know